ireland's decision to call a temporary
halt to the use of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
could have far-reaching consequences the
country's immunization authority pointed
to a safety alert raised this week
by the norwegian medicines agency after
four healthcare workers
suffered serious blood clotting events
within 14 days
of receiving the astrazeneca jab denmark
and iceland have raised similar concerns
with the ripple effect extending to
bulgaria and as far afield as
thailand the irish move was described
as precautionary we will continue to
monitor the situation and if we can be
satisfied that these events are
coincidental
and not caused by this vaccine we will
reassess the situation
the uk-based astrazeneca has defended
its vaccine
saying that safety data collected with
17 million doses administered so
far shows no evidence of increased risk
of pulmonary embolisms or thrombosis
pending further investigation the
european medicines agency
says the benefits of the vaccine
outweigh the risks
and the world health organization says
its rollout should continue
it really doesn't mean that it is
potentially unsafe
uh it has been tested widely there have
been no reported problems
uh beyond what you would normally expect
with a vaccine
with any vaccine and really the the
occurrence of
these thrombotic events these blood
clots uh is no greater in the vaccinated
population
than it is in the unvaccinated
population
so quite why regulators in these
countries have taken their decision
beyond being extremely cautious
is not really clear inevitably now
concerns will linger the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine has been beset by
problems including political disputes
and delivery delays
now add safety concerns it's important
to note that no one
is alleging a conclusive link between
the vaccine
and these blood clotting events but the
longer that doubt is allowed to persist
the worse the effect on trust and
therefore
the overall vaccine rollout jonah al
jazeera london